[Music]
the 2017 Emmys are almost here and
finally these small screen actors are
getting the big recognition they deserve
here's a look at some of our favorite
first-time Emmy nominees and you won't
believe who made the list it's so weird
I had to ask a couple times like did you
read it right you sure you sure that's
not like predictions is it real so um
but then I was like you know there's
really sunk in yet though to be honest
how does it feel to be a Emmy nominated
star here tonight so crazy I'm just so
thankful I don't think I would have
imagined this in a million years so I'm
kind of just trying to enjoy the ride
insanity insanity I just feel like a
dream congratulations
your first Emmy nomination how are you
feeling right now
overwhelmed I must say honestly I'm
feeling a bit overwhelmed I'm not sure
it's all sunk in yet
you know the validity of it in the air
the immensity of it but I'm honored and
I'm happy and pleased and my heart's
racing as I'm thinking about it you know
exciting and unexpected for me yeah it's
exciting it is exciting you know it's
hard not to be excited about these
things when when you're a kid you think
about them you think man I want to stand
on that stage I wanna win an award then
you get a little older and you think no
I just I just want to work I want to do
good work and then when you don't get
the nods and you go you know what I
don't need any of that I don't need any
of that to show up with a full heart
ready to do great work and then you get
the nomination you go okay back to work
you know so it's I'm humbled I'm honored
you know but at the same time it really
doesn't change the way I approach the
work it's always been the same
[Music]
you